hello freak [ __ ] well in it's
interesting we have these old variety
crabapples on my property Johnny
Appleseed kind of deal and that's what
Apple's effectively used to be we should
throw those at each other yeah yeah we
we make cider out of it it's pretty good
for that but if you pull up like a image
of what an original banana looks like
wow they're ridiculous like a seed yeah
it's tiny and it's all seeds and there's
hardly any edible structure to it and so
if you look at most of the fruit that
was available kind of pre agriculture
and that that selective breeding of
fruit like it was much smaller wasn't as
sweet and again it's not to say that you
shouldn't have any of that stuff but
it's just there was an interesting piece
that came out of the UK where it was
looking at feeding kids fruit they were
like let's let's recommend that these
kids eat fruit and the kids already had
a hyper caloric diet they were eating
too much they were eating too many carbs
and then they threw fruit on top of it
and they're like wow adding fruit to
this already shitty overeating program
made it worse you know and it was like
there was going to be some sort of magic
that came about out of adding some fruit
to this this story whereas the the kids
just needed to pull more of the junk out
and get some sort of both caloric
control and some carbohydrate control is
that it's really interests is there any
fruit that is in its original state like
maybe pomegranates they come berries are
pretty pretty you know
blueberries blackberries yeah yeah
they're pretty similar to berries yeah
yep that sweet not that sweet no
different different flavor yeah I know
yeah I've picked them like in the wild
like in in the backcountry right like a
blueberry just like hmm it's not bad but
it's not spectacular it's not what
you're used to
yeah yeah but oranges clearly they have
been [ __ ] with right yeah apples like
we were on a trip once and we bought
these apples and they were literally
like the size of a softball right and
you bite into it it's like the most
delicious dessert you could ever have
like this can't be a [ __ ] real
regular Apple right something's been
going store Noble Apple
how much of our food I mean especially
our fruit how much of it is genetically
altered it's got to be massive amounts
yeah and you know that that GMO story
I'm in a spot where I usually piss
everybody off about it because I am way
less concerned about genetic
modification of these things and more
concerned about some of the business
practices that happen like we've been
doing selective breeding for thousands
of years and there has modified the
genetics back to the earth turning into
dog story like that tomatoes everything
and without I mean that the classic
thoughts of frankenfoods
right meaning laboratory some sort of
injection into this not what's going on
selective breeding for the most part
yeah most of its selective breeding in
the the thing about GMO too is the
apologist for it like when you look at
the results that you get with the the
GMO the genetic modification it's really
unimpressive I mean it's not like
dramatically increasing yields is it
what inevitably is doing is creating
something that's usually more resistant
to Roundup than what the last thing was
roundup being that way yeah yeah which
is legitimately some pretty nasty stuff
and so it doesn't really seem to be
working any type of magic as far as like
feeding the world or anything like that
it is creating a funnel where in order
to grow this thing you need more
chemical fertilizer input you need more
pesticide employed and it just seems to
be the speed forward mechanism on that
and so I'm really from a health
standpoint I'm not that freaked out
about GMOs just as a baseline but from a
a really shady business practice I'm not
a big fan from actually moving the
needle on food production it's really
unimpressive to me so I my position on
GMOs usually just makes everybody mad
because I'm not really jumping into
either one of these these camps whole
hog well food production in general when
you look at these gigantic large-scale
farms that is that is one of the most
unnatural things you're ever gonna see
in life right these giant corn fields
right it's so unnatural right mono crop
yeah and not only the mono crop but
those are genetically modified mono
crops and you know and you want to kill
off all the weeds right
spraying your genetically modified mono
crops with some [ __ ] that kills off
everything but your genetically modified
mono crops and who knows what that
consequence is on the human body well
you know so what roundup is now being
suggested or has been suggested for a
long time as a mitochondrial disrupter
similar to that antibiotic story so this
is where people you know the last
questions about like well what about
this gluten intolerance thing like
people didn't have it fifty years ago
why is it going on now and we really
don't know but maybe it's antibiotics
maybe it's changes and gut microbiome
but a lot of this stuff seems to have a
mitochondrial dysfunction piece to it
Parkinson's Alzheimer's type 2 diabetes
they all seem to have mitochondrial
dysfunction elements to them the
mitochondria is not producing energy the
way that it should and back again to
that point about being flexible with our
fuel systems people seem to becoming
inflexible in their fuel systems and
this ketotic state may be the default
that we're able to go back to to be able
to maintain some degree of health and it
also seems to press a reset button in
the mitochondria where we get apoptosis
and cell death and abnormal cells but
the need for people to shift towards a
lower carb diet may be reflective of
some changes in the environment where
we're being made sick by things like
glyphosate or maybe an a over-aggressive
antibiotic use and then the thing that
we need to default back to to be able to
be healthy is some sort of low carb or
ketu ketogenic diet
[Applause]
[Music]